on the outside it may seem like we
haven't changed much from our early
ancestors but take a closer look and
you'll discover that humans are still
evolving in some fascinating new ways
folding your breath the average person
can hold their breath for 30 seconds but
the gel people in Southeast Asia can
hold it up to 12 minutes which comes in
handy when they freedive over 230 feet
for food part of the reason is simply
training and experience since they spend
over half their workday underwater but
it turns out the Bajau also have a
genetic mutation that makes their
screams 50% larger than average our
spleens are what filter and store oxygen
rich red blood cells so when the Bajau
dive underwater their largest spleens
contract which boosts oxygen levels in
the blood by up to 10 percent allowing
them more time to collect food it's a
handy adaptation that probably came from
living on houseboats for the last 1,000
years
drinking milk about 35% of the world's
population has the equivalent of a
genetic superpower they can digest milk
as adults not impressed then consider
this humans are among the only mammals
on the planet with this ability thanks
to a genetic mutation that popped up in
Europe around five to ten thousand years
ago those with the mutation produce
lactase throughout their lives that's
the enzyme that breaks down milk sugars
for easy digestion and for most of
history humans stopped producing lactase
after childhood but once those lucky few
Europeans could drink milk as adults
that suddenly meant extra nutrition and
ultimately healthier longer lives so
that they could pass their superpower on
to future generations today roughly 95
percent of Northern Europeans have the
mutation fending off disease the human
body has an estimated twenty to thirty
thousand genes and while some mutations
can change our spleens and diet others
can protect us against deadly conditions
like AIDS nearly 50 percent of women in
parts of South Africa have HIV but
research has found that some shows
stronger resistance to the virus taking
longer to develop AIDS or sometimes
never getting it at all
turns out these women also share a
mutation in a gene called HLA b27 that
the others lack are we going to evolve
our way to hate dr v immunity it's too
early to say but one thing is clear
evolutions not done with us yet
[Music]